wesh wesh wesh tennis kapoor brut pour
moi un des moments qui m'a marqué dans
ma vie je vais parler du freestyle
matuidi charreaux je pense que ça c'est
quand même un tournant dans ma vie et
dans ma carrière musicale
la première fois que je me rappelle que
matuidi avait fait avait repris un autre
gestuelle pour sa célébration
je me rappelle la toute première fois je
dormais je dormais mon téléphone est
marié
tellement que ça sonne et a sonné a
sonné baptisera calais pour regarder les
vidéos et où j'ai vu que ça j'étais trop
content je sais comment on fait moi j'ai
le droit tout début ça fait six mois
qu'on commence à voir le jour tu vois ça
ça reste un grand point d'autre choix au
même pour moi c'est un truc de ouf tout
ce que ça a pu amener derrière c'est à
dire la célébration de matuidi sur sur
le terrain même des marques il a repris
aussi qu elle était venue au psg
l'explosion du morceau qui a touché pas
mal de france qui m'a fait connaître
aussi au niveau vraiment en national et
qui a même fini dans dans l'est dans les
jeux vidéo tu vois fifa genre tu voyais
la célébration la danse tout tout tout
ce qui a pu se passer autour de ce
morceau je pense que ça a eu un rôle
important pour moi
la naissance de mon premier fils à 16
ans à 16 ans 3 gt j'étais jeune je
d'avoir un enfant c'était difficile
comme on l'expliquait à la daronne
comment l'expliquer à la famille et puis
tu sais que tu quand tu sors dehors un
peu tu as un peu montrée du doigt en
mode assez lui regardez c'est lui qui à
l enfance et lui s'est lui cassé donc un
truc tu vois c'était un peu ça dans la
ville et houdain autour de moi donc
c'était un peu c'était un sentiment un
peu bizarre tu vois à la fois tu es
content mais à la fois tu as un peu gêné
t4 et a un peu honte était mais après il
faut vite comprendre que tu dit un
responsable tu deviens responsable et
que voilà il ya un deuxième toi et que
agent du tube tu dois pas de penser qu'à
toi lors d'études a pensé à toi et au
fiston
donc ouais ça m'a moi je pense que ça
m'a apporté beaucoup en maturité et ça a
pris en tout responsabiliser des oufs
troisième maman qui m'a le plus marqué
est enfin là quand je réfléchis comme ça
on va dire que c'est mon les concerts en
afrique
les concerts en afrique marqué à la fois
choqué choqué de ouf
je faisais ma musique dans mon petit
their que c'était écouter à evry dans le
4e rang à l'est on a vu la france c'est
du bruit dans quelques coins de la
france mais pas non plus en afrique va
pas on voyait pas la chose comme ça donc
été au début j'appréhendais touches
multimédias écoute vraiment aimé comment
les écouter toutes choisi gerbe et
j'arrivais tout est je crois la toute
première fois que j'ai fait un truc en
afrique c'est au sénégal
j'avais fait un show-case c'était le
bordel c'était le bordel moi même
j'étais choqué soit j'étais choqué en
plus j'étais parti en vacances la
baronne à la base c'est à dire moi je
montrais était à ma demande mais oui
c'est un truc de ouf la moins chère du
monde isa connaissez mes paroles et où
c'était un délire tu vois et de ça est
vraiment pour continuer dans l'afrique
tu vois je me rappelle la première fois
où j'ai mis les pieds à brazzaville tu
vois en 2000 c'était l'année dernière en
2018 première fois tu vois j'ai
d'origine congolaise mais là c'était
vraiment la première fois donc je crois
pour marc fois que je viens au pays avec
tout ce buzz tout ce succès c'était un
truc de ouf je te laisse imaginer dans
mon grand père qui est dans son petit
coin depuis x années tard il est là pour
son petit cocon aujourd'hui j'arrive
chez lui tu vois tout quartier dont dans
sa maison c'est un truc de ouf voilà
c'était un délire non c'était émouvant
en tout cas c'est aider c'est un truc
que j'ai kiffé de ouf
franchement c'est ça restera jamais sa
bouche à la conception de l'album
commando tu vois l'album commando pas ce
que c'était c'était c'était un délire tu
vois surtout qu'on a on a lancé réseau
après et qui on a vu comment ça
s'attendait surtout pas ça si on était
un peu on était là aux mondes on va
faire comment les théâtres de faire des
stratégies et tout est mouvement jour on
balance réseau on voit ce que le morceau
effet c'était un carton plein c'était un
délire aujourd'hui tu vois que l'album
effet disque de diamant
sa légèreté choqué tu dis mais comment
genre avec mon père à homo de saâles et
aujourd'hui j'arrive à faire des trucs
comme as
[Musique]